Speaker 1: Welcome to the show, everybody, lots
of big news to talk about, including some really
important pharmaceutical developments, as we might
call them. Merck is now pushing into the Emergency
Use Authorization Request Phase, a so-called COVID
pill that they say based on their trials reduces
the risk of hospitalization and death by about
50 percent. Now my view on this has been that
politics aside, having an effective treatment
in addition to a vaccine is a really great
thing. There's a lot of people thinking about
this in the context of the unvaccinated. Well,
now the unvaccinated don't have to worry because
they can take a pill if they get the virus
and it cuts risk of hospitalization and death by
50 percent. There may be people that are going to
think about it that way, but not me. Let's talk
about the developments and then we will go from
there. Merck says COVID pill cuts risk of death
and hospitalization in a potential leap forward in
the global fight against the pandemic. Drugmaker
Merck said Friday that its experimental pill for
people sick with COVID reduced hospitalizations
and deaths by half. If cleared by regulators,
it would be the first pill shown to treat
COVID 19, adding a whole new easy to use weapon
to an arsenal that already includes the vaccine.
The company said it will soon ask health officials
in the U.S. and around the world to authorize
the pills, use a decision from the U.S. Food and
Drug Administration could come within weeks. After
that, all other COVID treatments authorized in the
U.S. require an IV or an injection. A pill taken
at home, by contrast, would ease pressure pressure
on hospitals and could also help curb outbreaks
in poorer and more remote corners of the world
that don't have access to the more expensive
infusion therapies. This would allow us to
treat many more people much more quickly, and we
trust much less expensively. Merck and its partner
Ridgeback Biotherapeutics as early, said early
results showed patients who received the drug
molnupiravir within five days of COVID symptoms
had about half the rate of hospitalization and
death as those who received a dummy pill the
placebo. The study tracked 775 adults with
mild to moderate COVID, considered high risk for
disease because of health problems like obesity,
diabetes or heart disease. The results have
not yet been reviewed by outside experts.
The usual procedure for vetting new medical
research among patients taking molnupiravir,
seven point three percent were either
hospitalized or died at the end of 30 days,
compared with 14 percent of those getting the
dummy pill. That is a significant reduction
after that time period. There were no deaths among
those who received the drug, compared with eight
deaths in the placebo group. This is one of those
cases we've talked about before medical ethics.
When the test, a medication or procedure
seems to be working so well, it becomes
unethical to keep people on the placebo. And
in fact, that's what they talk about here.
The results were so strong that an independent
group of medical experts monitoring the trial
recommended stopping it early. Executives plan
to submit data to the FDA in the coming days,
and experts stress the importance of getting
vaccinated anyway. So again, a lot of people
hearing this and saying, we've been saying
there's going to be a treatment of some kind,
we don't need to get vaccinated. That's not at all
what this is about. My thinking is the following
math. This is a great additional layer in addition
to vaccination. We've talked so much about,
you know, I did what was available to me. I
went and got the vaccine. And yet it's not 100
percent. No vaccine is 100 percent and immunity
may wane, as is often the case with vaccines.
We're trying to figure out. To what degree and how
much and how much in relation to the mutations of
the coronavirus. But we've done all those things
and yet we could still get it and we could get
really sick and we could die. So what do you do?
Well, here we have something that's an additional
barrier. It's not something to justify getting
no vaccine. Imagine that your risk of death is
90 percent lower with the vaccine. So OK, let's
say the overall infection fatality rate of COVID
is zero point eight. Why are we saying zero point
eight? Well, officially is one point six percent,
but we have reason to believe that the real number
of infections is actually two or even up to three
times the number of cases that are officially
known. So that would put the infection fatality
rate in reality somewhere between zero point
four and 0.8. Let's call it zero point eight. OK,
so I get the vaccine. These are rough numbers.
I get the vaccine, and let's say that reduces
risk of death by 90 percent. I've gone now
risk of death wise from zero point eight to
zero point zero eight. I have reduced my risk of
death dramatically on an infection basis. If this
pill then cuts it by 50 percent, you're talking
about vaccine plus having the COVID pill if you
get sick as two things together, that would drop
your risk of death to zero point zero four percent
now for the unvaccinated. It also cuts it,
but it remains 10 times higher. If you if
you eliminate the vaccine layer of protection,
the risk of death is zero point eight percent.
If you get sick, you take the pill that drops,
it, drops it to zero point four percent, me,
I would prefer zero point zero four percent is my
risk of death rather than zero point four percent.
That's just me. You could do the calculations
you want, but that's sounding pretty good to me.
So this will be submitted for emergency use. And
by the way, I'm going to get ahead of one thing.
There are tons of anti-vaxxers who have been
saying, I'm not taking an experimental vaccine
who are already saying, Look, the COVID pill.
We knew it was coming. I don't need the vaccine
because of the COVID pill. This is just as
experimental in the sense that it doesn't yet
even have emergency use authorization. If it gets
it, it will have the status of the vaccines have
had for a year. Only a month ago or so roughly was
the Pfizer vaccine actually fully approved. So if
your reason all along for not taking the vaccine
was, it's experimental in the sense that it's UUA
emergency use approved. The best case scenario for
the COVID pill that you might use to justify not
getting a vaccine is that it would have that
same emergency use authorization status. So
these people are pathetic. We know that this to
me, is not an alternative to vaccination. It's if
you get vaccinated and you unfortunately get sick
anyway, which is not super likely right now. But
it does happen statistically. Not super likely.
Most of the infections are in the unvaccinated.
You have another layer of protection,
and that's a really, really good thing.